so we have the graph of y is equal to g
of x right over here and i want to think
about what is the limit
as x approaches 5
of g of x
well we've done this multiple times
let's think about what g of x approaches
as x approaches 5 from the left
g of x is approaching negative 6.
as x approaches 5 from the right g of x
looks like it's approaching negative 6.
so a reasonable estimate based on
looking at this graph is that as x
approaches 5 g of x is approaching
negative 6.
and it's worth noting that that's not
what g of 5 is g of 5 is a different
value
but the whole point of this video is to
appreciate all that a limit does a limit
only describes the behavior of a
function as it approaches a point it
doesn't tell us exactly what's happening
at that point what g of 5 is and it
doesn't tell us much about the rest of
the function about the rest of the graph
for example i could construct many
different functions for which the limit
as x approaches 5 is equal to negative 6
and they would look very different from
g of x for example i could say the limit
of f of x
as x approaches 5 is equal to negative 6
and i can construct an f x that does
this that looks very different than g of
x and in fact if you're up for it pause
this video and see if you could do the
same if you have some graph paper or
even just sketch it
well the key thing is that the behavior
of the function as x approaches 5 from
both sides from the left and the right
it has to be approaching negative 6.
so for example
a function that looks like this
so let me draw f of x
and f of x that looks like this
and is even defined right over there and
then does something like this
that would work as we approach from the
left we're approaching negative six as
we approach from the right we are
approaching negative six
you could have a function
like
this let's say the limit
let's call it h of x as x approaches 5
is equal to negative 6.
you could have a function like this
maybe it's defined up to there
then it's you have a circle there and
then it keeps going
[Music]
maybe
maybe it's not defined at all for any of
these values and then maybe down here it
is defined for all x values greater than
or equal to 4 and it just goes right
through negative 6.
so notice
all of these all of these functions as x
approaches 5. they all have the limit
defined and it's equal to negative 6 but
these functions all look very very very
different
now another thing to appreciate is for a
given function and let me delete these
often times we're asked to find the
limits as x approaches some type of an
interesting value so for example x
approaches 5 5 is interesting right over
here because we have this point
discontinuity but you could take the
limit on an infinite number of points
for this function right over here you
could say the limit
of g of x
as x approaches not x equals
as x
approaches
1. what would that be positive and try
to figure it out
let's see as x approaches 1 from the
left hand side
it looks like
we are approaching this value here
and as x approaches
1 from the right hand side it looks like
we are approaching that value there so
that would be equal to g of 1. that is
equal to g of 1 based on that would be a
reasonable
that's a reasonable conclusion to make
looking at this graph and if we were
estimate that g of 1 is looks like it's
approximately negative 5.1 or 5.2
negative
5.1 we could find the limit
of g of x as x approaches
pi
so pi is right around there as x
approaches pi
from the left we're approaching that
value which just looks actually pretty
close to the one we just thought about
and as we approach from the right we're
approaching that value and once again in
this case this is going to be equal to g
of pi we don't have any interesting
discontinuities there or anything like
that
so there's two big takeaways here
you can construct many different
functions that would have the same limit
at a point and for a given function you
can take the limit at many different
points in fact an infinite number of
different points uh and and it's
important to point that to point that
out no pun intended because oftentimes
we get used to seeing limits only at
points where something strange seems to
be happening